welcome everyone this is part three in
our series on presenting your research
we're going to be talking about the
sometimes thrilling and sometimes
agonizing process of submitting your
work for publication at an nlp
conference
to start i want to review what's known
as the anonymity period for acl
conferences
uh all of the acl conferences that have
adopted a uniform policy that submitted
papers cannot be uploaded to
repositories like archive or made public
in other ways starting one month from
the submission deadline and extending
through the time when decisions go out
so you should be aware of this and for
specific conferences check their sites
for the precise date when the embargo
goes into effect so that you're sure
you're playing by the rules
the rationale the policy is an attempt
to balance the benefits of free and fast
distribution of new ideas against the
benefits of double blind peer review the
idea is that we want to avoid
corrupting reviewers just at the moment
they sit down to begin their work of
reviewing by con by having them see on
archive or via twitter an announcement
about the paper they're reviewing that
reveals the authors and the origins and
so forth because we know that that
public announcement would influence
their decision-making process
so to kind of preserve that
but balance that against free
dissemination of ideas we have this
embargo period around the period when we
know reviewing will happen
for more on the policy and its rationale
you can follow this link here but i
would say that fundamentally it's an
attempt to balance these two pressures a
kind of pragmatic approach to balancing
them
okay now let's dive into the actual
process of submitting work for
publication and having it go through
review at one of these conferences so to
start let's suppose you've submitted
your paper when you do that you'll
select some area keywords that will help
determine which committee gets your
paper this is already a really important
step you'll be choosing from a bunch of
keywords that signal different areas of
nlp and what you're doing at that point
is probably routing your paper to
certain sets of reviewers and certain
area chairs and so forth and in doing
that you're creating expectations about
the kind of contribution that you're
making
so if you're unsure about this process i
would encourage you to recruit an expert
in the nlp reviewing process to help you
make these keyword selections here's an
example of how this could be important
suppose that your paper is fundamentally
a new machine learning contribution but
it reports some experiments that involve
kind of topics in computational social
science it might be really a mistake to
choose the computational social science
keyword at this point because if your
paper ends up with reviewers who have
expectations that you'll be making some
new and fundamental contribution to that
area and what they're looking at is a
machine learning contribution that
mismatch in their expectations might
lead them to have a negative perception
of the work
and the reverse of course holds as well
if you have a fundamentally new
computational social sciences
contribution but it incidentally makes
use of some machine learning apparatus i
think it would be a mistake to choose
machine learning as a keyword precisely
because of that mismatch and
expectations that would result in
reviewers minds when they sat down and
started reviewing your paper so think
strategically about this stage you can
see why it's important at this next
stage here
reviewers
when they begin their work they're going
to first scan a long list of titles and
abstracts and they'll make bids on which
ones they want to do at this point they
signal yes or maybe or no or maybe they
indicate a conflict of interests
indicating that they can't review the
paper at all
when they do this the title is probably
the primary factor in bidding decisions
they probably have access to the
abstract at this stage but they might be
looking at a list of over 200 different
contributions and it's probably just too
much to ask that they would read all of
these abstracts at this stage so they're
probably scanning the title and using
that as an indication about what kind of
bids they want to make so again you
might think strategically about your
title and the role it will play at this
early stage in the process
after that the program chairs assign
reviewers their papers partly based on
the bidding but maybe partly based on
other considerations of workloads and so
forth we don't know precisely how that
process will happen but by some
mechanism
your paper will be assigned probably
three different reviewers
reviewers read the papers write comments
and supply ratings over the course of a
few months
at the very end of that process authors
are typically allowed to respond briefly
to the reviews
and then the program chair or the area
chair might seek to simulate some
discussion among the reviewers about
conflicts between their reviews or maybe
places where the author response says
the reviewers are incorrect or misguided
or something we hope that that's a
lively and rich discussion about the
paper
that's led by open-minded people who are
just trying to arrive at the best
possible recommendation for your paper
that's what we hope at this stage in the
process
then finally at the very end the program
committee is going to do some magic to
arrive at the final program based on all
of this input of course their reviews
and ratings will be a major factor but
there might be other considerations that
they bring in at this stage in terms of
constructing a diverse and interesting
program for their conference
at this stage you might get a meta
review that provides some insight into
the final decision-making process
although those vary and the amount that
they actually illuminate the
behind-the-scenes process that led to
the particular recommendation that was
made by the reviewers and area chair
in terms of the work that the actual
reviewers are doing i would say that the
current acl setup is kind of oriented
around structured text for the reviews
as opposed to providing a lot of
metadata via ratings
so first they'll probably be asked to
just indicate what the paper is about
what contributions it makes and what its
main strengths and weaknesses are this
is a kind of check that they actually
understand what's in the paper and can
articulate what's in the paper and it
gives a first indication of their
assessment
next you have reasons to accept and
reasons to reject
then there could be a section for
additional questions and feedback for
the authors
maybe the reviewers can indicate missing
references and maybe also a catch-all
section for typos grammar style and
presentation improvements and so forth
then of course you get two really
important ratings the overall
recommendation
and maybe an assessment of the reviewers
confidence in their overall evaluation
and then finally there could be a
section for confidential information
that the reviewers want to communicate
directly to the program committee and
that would be hidden from the authors as
well as the other reviewers
so stepping back the most important
pieces of this reviewing form are
obviously the overall recommendation
possibly balanced against reviewer
confidence
and the reasons to accept and reasons to
reject you can count on the two texts
that they supply
under two and three here as being really
important to shaping the discussion that
happens and the overall recommendation
that gets made
there's an author response period for at
least the major acl conferences this is
a chance for authors to submit short
responses to the reviews
this is a rather uncertain business
along many dimensions so let me just
offer some thoughts
first many people are cynical about
author responses since they've observed
that reviewers rarely change their
scores afterwards and i think that is an
important consideration
however it might just be bad signaling
not to submit a response at all it could
incidentally indicate to the program
committee that you've kind of silently
opted out of the process so its mere
absence could reduce your chances of
getting accepted i believe
more positively for conferences that
have area chairs and i believe all the
current major acl conferences do the
author response could be really
important an area chair is someone who's
tasked with stimulating discussion and
might writing meta reviews for a small
number of papers maybe five to twenty
depending on the conference volume
and for those people the author response
might have a major impact i've played
the role of area chair many times and
the author responses are always valuable
to me it's another text alongside the
reviews that the um reviewers provided
and it helps me understand places of
conflict places where the um authors
differ in their perspective from the
reviewers and so forth it is always
extremely valuable evidence to me
and i think that holds for many area
chairs and for this reason alone you
might think about submitting a detailed
author response with these area chairs
in mind as your primary readers
nlp conferences for better or worse have
very complex rules about what you can
and can't say in these author responses
sometimes you can't report any new
results sometimes you have to be very
circumspect about what kind of results
you have and so forth if you have
questions about what you can do in a
particular case seek out an expert at
stanford for advice on how to interpret
the precise rules and what kind of
leeway you actually have in saying what
you think is important to say i think
all of these restrictions are kind of
unfortunate when i play the role of area
chair and as reviewer i would simply
like to have access to all the
information that i can possibly obtain
and so i would like these author
responses to be
offering as much information as they
feel is important and then i can use
that to balance all the evidence to make
a final recommendation
so it's unfortunate from my perspective
that these have restrictions at all but
they're often there and it's important
to figure out how to navigate them
when you construct an author response
always be polite you can be firm and
direct but you'll want to do that
strategically to signal what you feel
most strongly about but fundamentally
you should never say things like this
your inattentiveness is embarrassing
section 6 does what you say we didn't do
you might privately say that to your
co-authors as a kind of cathartic act of
venting about how bad your reviews were
but you should never put it in an author
response rather you should do things
that are more like thank you the
information you're requesting is in
section six we will make this more
prominent in our revision fundamentally
here i think it's just important to be
polite in these professional contexts
and it's a way to remind yourself that
these reviewers did make an investment
of their own time and intellectual
energy into your work and we want to be
respectful and aware of that investment
that they made
prison types presentation types and
venues there are lots of them so first
there's the fundamental distinction you
might have either oral presentations or
poster presentations and cross-cutting
that you might think about submitting to
a workshop or to a main conference
here's a whole bunch of venues and what
i've done here is kind of organize this
in a soft way
so on the left here i have nlp
conferences and workshops
i've put like what we consider the most
prestigious three at the top here acl
mackel and emnlp
and then some other large ones just
below that
of course the prestige order could
really change here so who knows what the
next years will bring for example the
asia acl is brand new and of course the
number of people doing outstanding work
in our area throughout asia is enormous
and so it's very easy for me to imagine
that aacl becomes at least as prominent
maybe even more prominent than some of
these other ones up here over the next
few years
then we have some smaller and older
conferences down here and then of course
at the bottom i put workshops all of
these major conferences have workshop
series attached to them
and workshops can be a great initial
outlet for work you do especially for a
course like this so i would encourage
you for the major conferences to scan
their program of workshops and if you
find one that's topically aligned with
what you're working on consider
submitting to the workshop it will
probably be less competitive so you have
better chances of getting in but i would
say the more important thing is that
it's a chance for you to actually
connect with a community of people who
are working on precisely the topic that
you're working on and that can be
intellectually really exciting
in the middle here i have some
conferences that kind of run
the the spectrum from linguistics
through the world wide web through
knowledge graphs and kind of more top
more core topics in
artificial intelligence generally and
those can be really good outlets for
work that has an nlp aspect to it and
then over here on the right these are
very prestigious machine learning
conferences and it's kind of the same
story all of these conferences here are
welcoming of work that involves natural
language processing but you might just
have to think about how you're going to
precisely connect with these specific
audiences and their specific concerns
here's my personal assessment of nlp
reviewing at present
first i think the focus on conference
papers as opposed to journals has been
really good for nlp it fits with and
encourages the very rapid pace of our
field and i think we all benefit from
that rapid pace overall
before about 2010 the reviewing in the
field was admirably good and rigorous in
comparison with other fields it really
was impressive
how many deep and insightful reviews you
would get when you submitted to one of
the main conferences in the field
lately though
the explosive growth of the field has i
think by consensus reduce the general
quality of reviewing and the field is
still grappling with this
of course there was always a kind of
lottery aspect to whether your paper
would be accepted and you should keep in
mind that luck is a real element in
publication and throughout science
but that lottery aspect has gotten more
amplified as the field has grown and
that's affecting the main conferences in
ways that we all have to figure out but
again this is kind of useful keep in
mind that a rejection does not
necessarily mean that your work was of
low quality it could mean that you just
had really bad luck throughout a kind of
chaotic reviewing process
i also want to say that i think it's
unhealthy to force every paper to be
four or eight pages the reason that
happens is that there are two kinds of
submission typically a short paper which
has max length four and a long paper
which has max length eight and we all as
submitters to one or another of those
tracks feel a kind of signaling pressure
to maximize the available space so there
are like no six page papers in the field
and there was really no room to have
papers that are longer than eight pages
and that's unfortunate because sometimes
you just need a different length than
one of these to express your ideas in
the best possible way
so that's been unhealthy i will say
though that this is alleviated somewhat
by the increased use of appendices and
supplementary materials to express a lot
of details that don't need to be part of
the main narrative and that is in effect
via a back door allowing papers to be of
more variable length
the biggest failing to my mind of the
conference reviewing process is that
there's no revise and resubmit as you
standardly get from journals there's no
chance for authors to appeal to an
editor and interact with an editor in a
way that you get from really top quality
journals and that just introduces
inefficiency into the system and it's a
missed opportunity for intellectual
engagement that could really benefit the
work
i do want to say though there's hope the
transactions of the acl or tackle is a
journal that follows the standard acl
conference model fairly closely but
allows for journal style interaction
with an editor i'm conflicted here
because i've been a tackle action editor
for a very long time but i do that work
because i think tackle is wonderful it's
allowing for the best aspects of our
field in terms of fast pace
while also introducing some healthy
aspects of the journal reviewing process
tackle papers are a little bit longer at
10 pages so there's still some of this
problematic influence under 4 here but
at least they are
a bit longer
and overall i think it's just a
healthier rhythm for thinking about
evaluating work in these scientific
contexts so think about tackle as an
outlet for your work as well
let's focus on two more specific topics
here starting with titles as i said
before a title is an important
ingredient in the fate of your paper and
conference reviewing
jokey titles can be risky and i've
linked to some evidence for that down
here in this paper
more importantly you might think that
it's important calibrate the scope of
your contribution in your title it's a
very common complaint from reviewers
that the title is an overreach that it
claims a broader spectrum of the
scientific space than the paper actually
delivers on and you want to avoid that
by getting a tight alignment between
title and paper
and then also consider the kinds of
reviewers you're likely to attract
during that bidding process the choices
you make in your title will definitely
influence that process and so you can
again think strategically about who you
want to pull in as a reviewer because of
their interests and expertise and so
forth
i would also say that it's worthwhile
avoiding special fonts and formatting if
possible just because it makes it harder
to consistently reproduce your title
that said i am kind of charmed by the
move to have emoji and titles recently
um jokey is risky um but this can be fun
and make your paper a bit memorable even
if it is harder to copy and paste the
title in various contexts
abstracts abstracts are also incredibly
important because after the title they
will create this first and lasting
impression so here's a suggestion about
how to think about writing abstracts
it's a difficult form
first have your opening be a broad
overview a glimpse at the central
problem in its context
next the middle takes concepts mentioned
in the opening and elaborates upon them
probably by connecting with specific
experiments and results from your paper
and then finally at the very end
establish links between your proposal
and broader theoretical concerns so that
the reviewer on finishing this abstract
has an answer to the question does the
abstract offer a substantial and
original proposal
so in a little more detail here's a kind
of
meta abstract
this opening sentence situates you dear
reader
our approach seeks to address the fallen
central issue you spell it out the
techniques we use are as follows and you
spell it out our experiments are these
details and then finally overall we find
that our approach has the following
properties and the significance of this
is and if you just fill in all those
ellipsis dots i think you're pretty
close to an effective abstract
and that's at least a starting point for
you when you think about maybe being
more creative and fitting this better to
the specifics of your ideas
style sheets this is small but important
this is the way that you could avoid the
dreaded dust reject
pay close attention to the details of
the style sheet for your conference and
any other requirements included in the
call for papers it is worth your while
to read those documents carefully and
make sure you've checked all the boxes
in nlp infractions are the most likely
cause of the dreaded desk project that
is rejection without review which is of
course so disheartening because you made
a big push to get your paper submitted
and then shortly thereafter you get this
desk project in the mail and there's no
recourse that's pretty much the end of
the process for you and you can avoid it
by just attending to what they've said
in their style sheets and other
guidelines
and then finally we have this charming
notion of a camera-ready version this
refers to old-fashioned technology for
publishing papers where you actually
needed to take pictures of documents in
order to publish them those days are
long gone but the terminology remains
for most nlp conferences as part of this
you get an additional page upon
acceptance this is presumably to respond
to requests made by reviewers although
in practice you're free to use the space
however you like
in general we find that the extra page
is mainly used for fixing passages that
we made overly terse at reviewing time
in order to get into the page limits and
now we're kind of unpacking them to make
them more readable this is obviously an
inefficient process but it's the reality
at present
you could of course use your uh
additional page to improve your results
in all sorts of ways it's entirely up to
you but a word of caution here
if you have very substantially new ideas
and results it might be better for you
to save those for a follow-up paper as
opposed to trying to pack them into work
that's already been accepted right
instead of just making more work for
yourself as part of this first
contribution it might be that you're on
the exciting path toward a follow-up
contribution that's going to be its
entirely own new paper
so think about that and balance these
pressures
and then good luck with your camera
ready submissions